e espero que aconteçam como acessá lo de
lá u é mais fácil controlar as imagens
jogamos o ano seguinte porque ela sempre
qualquer coisa que lhe dê lima e
organizada enquanto pisada agora
funciona com todos e é nesse sentido nós
lá e marketing
isso é antigo e foi ganhar maneiras de
lidar e em dois anos a pular com mais
pessoas
vou jogar mais soltos e mais como estas
e outras obras que ela tem de morar
conosco porque nós era um escândalo nos
braços e nos ganhos nesta manhã para as
fotos do computador para mais de chão e
entrou na dança foi e deu origem
a menina é o 11 9 o corpo se não
conseguir votar em si mesmo
o governo construiu a cidade e colocar
às 16 horas
agora é muito mais uma das mais baixas
votar na cidade aumentou porque isso é
normal
outros novos aos mais jovens
assassinados nos anos 60
isso é o óbvio que o governo e que vai
já na sua visão mais precisa sobre a
procura de ninguém
[Música]
a cidade do aço ninguém tem esse marco
de boxe marco do mar devem ser criados
porque o jorjão e nós temos mais um
carro espanhol foi melhor
vamos lá ou seja nós vamos mover uma
função da luminosidade e nem eu não sou
[Música]
uma voz da mãe diná
no entanto nossas costas
na foto a 14 a 18 segundos na rua jesus
cristo em nós
além disso milhares de pessoas e um raio
não importa se nada que eu não
trabalhava com a orelha também com
variações acumulada e já olha vou entrar
na província da fazenda nacional
segundo o jornal a bola
com essa mulher atendendo a um cartão só
tem a sua e nós vamos tirar a bola e nós
não é um adeus é só para nós agora
no dia 09 04 chegou da rua doy jorge
[Aplausos]